أنا د.  سانجاي غوبتا واليوم أود
أن أريكم جانبًا مختلفًا من دبي
بالتأكيد إنها مدينة معروفة
بناطحات السحاب وشواطئها
والتسوق ، لكن دبي لديها أيضًا الكثير من
أنواع الأنشطة المختلفة بما في ذلك
التزلج
والتزلج على الجليد الذي لم أره من قبل.  أي شيء
مشابه تمامًا لهذا الشيء غير
المنطقي حول التزلج في الداخل
الآن كما قد تتخيل الآن ، فهم
يوفرون لك جميع المعدات التي
تحتاجها بما في ذلك خوذة هنا
كطبيب أعصاب أعتقد شخصياً أن هذه
هي أهم قطعة دعنا نذهب
ونشعر وكأنني الشيء الحقيقي  سأعطي الفرصة
لوجود شيء
غير طبيعي حول التزلج في الصحراء ،
لكنني أعتقد أن مجرد شيء جديد منه يجعل هذا الأمر
غير عادي ممتعًا جدًا ، لذا من
كان يظن أنني أتيت
إلى الصحراء هنا في دبي و  أذهب
للتزلج على الجليد يا له من يوم رائع
[موسيقى]